with Trump's arrest looming he is now
begging for money begging for money
first and foremost Trump also dumping in
the George Soros stuff let me mention
that George Soros the club for no growth
and other globalist special interests
including the Koch family will spend
billions and billions of dollars against
us and they don't have our interest at
heart
they want a president that can be
controlled like a puppet and that's
exactly guys it's it's all the words
right Soros puppet globalist exactly
what they get with somebody like Joe
Biden instead our movement is funded by
Patriots like you who are fighting to
take our country back so the context
here is we need money to fight against
Soros and the indictment and the whole
thing and to make America great again
nothing terrifies Soros more than seeing
millions and millions of hard-working
Americans donating five twenty even
forty seven dollars there you go when
George Soros at age 92 plots against
Trump by getting him arrested and he
sees Joe Blow donating 47 dollars Soros
is just quaking in his boots look at the
imaginary fantasy world he has to create
in order to get people to donate money
to save our country from Democrats
destruction you see what they're doing
to our cities they're being destroyed
together we will make America great
again yeah yeah make America great again
Trump then posting also continuing to
ask for money on Truth social quote if
you're doing poorly as so many of you
are don't send anything if you're doing
well which was made possible through the
great policies of the Trump
Administration send your contribution to
donaldjtrump.com we have to take back
our Capital C country and all caps make
America great again that that's like a
little extra thing in there
if you're not doing well today it's
because of Joe Biden
if you are doing well today it's because
of my policies from years ago but send
Trump the money if you're doing well for
whatever reason send Trump the money
begging for cash as his arrest looms can
he even possibly raise enough money for
the number of criminal cases that there
could critical word could be
coming up against him we will see and we
will see if indeed he gets arrested
tomorrow